quién fue la presidenta interina de
bolivia hoy sufre en la cárcel ya ni me
años tuvo su gloria en la política en
noviembre de 2019 cuando el país ardía
en protestas las manifestaciones
comenzaron tras una apretada elección
presidencial en la que ganó evo morales
mientras la oposición denunció fraude
finalmente morales renunció luego de que
los policías se sumaron en los motines y
allí se proclamó como la nueva líder
interina por ser la presidenta del
senado sumó de inmediato la presidencia
del estado los co partidarios de morales
alegaron un golpe de estado y el ex
presidente comenzó a acusar a años por
los muertos de las protestas
mientras el pueblo humilde clama por paz
y diálogo el régimen de facto de camacho
mesa yáñez reprime con tanques y balas
desde su auto nombramiento ya causaron
24 muertos ayer 12 en sacaba todos
hermanos indígenas esa es la verdadera
dictadura que masacra sin clemencia
con años en el poder la fiscalía acusó a
evo morales- de terrorismo y la
situación se revirtió después de que la
oposición perdió las elecciones
presidenciales frente a luís arce el ex
ministro de economía de morales cinco
veces después la justicia ordenó prisión
preventiva para agnès acusando la de
sedición conspiración y terrorismo por
lo que pasó en 2019 y desde entonces ha
estado en la casa
su familia denuncia traslado sorpresivos
de prisión y en las últimas dos semanas
la llevaron tres veces al hospital por
hipertensión en un acto desesperado
intentó quitarse la vida porque ya no
aguantando todas estas injusticias todos
estos abusos de parte del gobierno el
proceso de años continúa con
manifestaciones a favor y en contra y
ahora el ex presidente deberá enfrentar
el genocidio y las lesiones de las que
la acusa